Scott Butterworth what's up hey oh man
so gears war for is fast approaching
October 11th it will release and it will
be the first original gears war game
from developer the coalition who took it
over from previous developer epic games
yes and of course a lot of people on the
coalition including Rod Fergusson worked
on the games but they have been showing
more and more gears for including pretty
much all their modes which you got to
play them yeah I just I just actually
visited the coalition up in Vancouver
and got a chance to play all three of
like sort of the major pillars of the
game versus modes the Horde and
single-player campaign cool yeah I think
that the most interesting stuff actually
was to my surprise the vs stuff I played
versus really early in the year and was
kind of like okay this feels a bit like
years but wasn't all that excited but it
probably got to play some of the new
modes and they were actually really
exciting really different the one mode
that's really different for Gears is a
mode called
escalation which they repeatedly told us
like oh this was built for eSports we
really wanted to have an eSports mode
and like I'm not a huge sports fan but I
will say that I I really love this mode
I can actually see this becoming like my
go-to gears mode just because there's so
much strategy built into it it's like
the the baseline gears gameplay is all
there it's all you know like well
bouncing and shotgunning for people who
want to do that kind of thing but it's
still like heavy and you know all the
movement and the grit and the cover of
you know the five versus five team gears
gameplay but layered on top of that are
all these new sort of structures that
make it way more team focused so
basically the way escalation works is
it's a best it's the first two seven
it's a round based mode and it's
basically a point capture system so
there are three points on the map every
point that you currently hold contribute
to your point total and once you get to
a certain point total you win that round
however in any given round you can also
win by controlling all three points at
the same time so no matter how far
behind your team is you can come back
and win the rounds like instantaneously
by dominating the map which is actually
really cool I mean just in the time that
I was playing it led to some really
great turnarounds yeah you could throw
up some like Hail Marys at the end I
would imagine yeah totally and it really
does make strategy much more important
because it's still a fun
person team on a map with free capture
points just doing the math it's like how
you cover all of those bases right so it
definitely made for some some really
interesting moment to moment like
tactical decisions with my teammates and
then in addition to that structure of
like the you know the six six you know
have to win seven rounds and and you
have to capture the three points in
between each round the respawn timer
actually goes up so by the time you get
to the sixth round it's like 20 seconds
or two advanced bonds so revives and and
keeping your teammates alive becomes
super crucial if your team lost the
previous round you actually get to place
a weapon on the map you don't get the
place whatever weapon you want anywhere
you want you get to pick from
pre-selected kind of like oh you can
place a boom shot here or you can place
a sniper there but your team gets to
pick where that goes
that definitely does sound esports
inspired with the increased respawn
timer and oh there's a few MOBAs that do
that and then the weapon placement kind
of seems like that like deeper strategic
layer underneath the foundational
mechanics of a Gears game yeah totally
and and you can actually go a lot of
different directions with it I mean so
if your team is really good at distance
or you liked it you know play the you
know spacing game you can put a sniper
down because you know your team's really
good post I / or you can just take a
completely different route and say hey
we're gonna put a boom shot over here as
bait let the other guys go for it and
know that's where the team's gonna be
and while they're off doing that we're
gonna go capture these other points
that's awesome umm yeah so there's all
kinds of different ways you can play it
and again this is all stuff that I got
through experience just with you know
people i sat down to play the game with
we didn't really plan we weren't really
a team this stuff was just kind of
naturally emerges as you're playing this
mode which is really cool
so you said there were a few other modes
you got the way right yeah so escalation
is by far the most kind of hardcore of
the new modes but they've also added
some just fun I hesitate to call them
casual modes but things that are
definitely designed to be more social
and more fun one of them was arms race
which is very similar to a movi you'll
find an overwatch and that gun game in
black ops where there is a series of 13
guns both teams start with the same guns
and after a team gets three kills with
that gun they then are downgraded to the
next gun below that so the guns actually
get worse as you go you start with a
boom shot and I'm pretty sure you end
just with a snub pistol dang um so it's
kind of cool because the team that's in
lead is constantly like added
disadvantage because they have the worst
weapons sure and it allows the team
behind them to kind of catch up and it's
insanely chaotic it's unbelievable the
amount of this carnage it's sort of the
opposite of escalation where you have to
be really strategic and how you're
moving how you're positioning and
keeping everybody alive arms race is
just like carnage everywhere at all
times everyone running and everyone's
shooting and there were definitely some
hilarious moments where at one moment
you have like an Asscher in your hands
and then all of a sudden you have a
sniper rifle and you're right next to
someone and it's it can be a little
frustrating at times and I sort of wish
the respawn timer was lower because
given how fast-paced the game is it's
really frustrating to be out of the
match but it's just so chaotic it's a
really nice change of pace from like the
seriousness and strategy of something
like escalation
I sound like especially kind of like it
upsets the gears for me like it's so
much of gears is like noticing someone
has an Asscher here someone has a sniper
so I'm gonna take cover but that sounds
like it could lead to like some crazy
twist in the gameplay
Hodel yeah and I think that was very
intentional on the coalition's part
they're like okay what can we do to kind
of mess with the formula so it doesn't
just feel like years cuz it's important
to mention that execution like the
classic team deathmatch mode that has
been in Gears forever is still there and
hasn't changed as far as you know we
actually didn't get a chance to play it
but they were we were told during a
presentation at the epic Coalition like
hey this hasn't changed at all it's
still there it's still execution for
people who want classic Gears it's there
we're just adding new things in addition
to that right um another one that they
added that's also kind of casual and fun
and and potentially a lease is some
really amazing reversals and turnarounds
was dodgeball is that that's a mode we
actually did get a chance to play
earlier this year about had another
chance to play at this past week yeah um
for anybody who hasn't followed the game
basically the way the dodge ball works
is every time you get a kill one of your
dead teammates is brought back in so you
can go from being like five versus one
to suddenly four versus to back to three
versus three and you can really turn the
tables as you're like if you're the last
man standing you're not necessarily
alone like if you can get one kill you
can claw your way back from the brink of
defeat a really cool here's the void
like being outnumbered and try to
isolate one person so then like each
time you have another person your team
it's kind of like like a an attrition
gameplay or like tug of war almost
that's super appealing that's the mode
I'm looking forward to most yeah totally
and yeah just in my time with it it's
there are some like those moments when
there's one guy left and his entire team
is watching him and like ah come on man
you can do it and he gets that kill like
the room just celebration like it's
built for that man yeah I mean I hate to
use the phrase because this is the PR
phrase they were pushing on us but it's
totally built for like clutch moments
like that proved true in my time to the
game I will say that if you if the teams
are kind of unbalanced the mode sort of
falls apart like if you were on a team
that is clearly worse than the other
team it's just like instant slaughter
because there are no respawn so you have
like no recourse no way to kind of fight
your way back if you're not able to get
that one crucial kill definitely so it
can feel if the teams are not balanced
it yeah it becomes actually even more
frustrating than certain other
modes but as long as you you're
confident in your teammates and as long
as the matchmaking does its job it ends
up being a really interesting mode and
again just a nice change of pace from
traditional straight up t-shirt match so
I guess the overarching question about
multiplayer that I have is obviously at
its foundation that's very mechanically
similar to earlier Gears titles are
these modes doing enough to set it apart
in your opinion from the few hours that
you've spent with it does this like
would this be enough to put me as a
Gears fan back into the multiplayer mix
I think absolutely yeah I mean you know
it's a little too early to judge the you
know the final review build isn't gonna
be in for a few weeks but I I had a
blast and honestly like it it is still
Kear's it plays like gears it feels like
years the classic modes like execution
are still in there but there's enough
new stuff that you can engage with if
you want that I think will bring in fans
and people who have kind of fallen away
from Gears because that stuff is
genuinely new like escalation is a
genuinely new idea for Gears and it
really makes the game play the moments
moment gameplay kind of more meaningful
and more tense because I mean it's not
just about staying alive or having a
good you know kill death ratio it's
about dominating these points and
working with your team to like outsmart
the other team and she does all that
strategy on top of the traditional Gears
gameplay really does change the way you
approach Gears so yeah I honestly think
it's a really smart and comprehensive
approach to multiplayer that hopefully
and I think will bring old fans back to
the series awesome that's exciting
we also have some coverage on horde mode
we have videos we have your written
piece that you did as well the campaign
written piece that you did we got to
play through a little bit as JD Phoenix
yeah yeah it's really interesting
there's a lot of new story stuff I
definitely recommend people go if
they're at all interested in the lore of
gears and world of Gears please go read
my single-player campaign feature
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff I got to play and yeah I got a
little more hands-on time with bored
mode but we played a ton of that impact
so we also have videos on the site for
the first 10 waves playing or 3.0 which
is also like way more strategic now than
it used to be really fun it's definitely
worth going to check in that content
for sure cool so gears war for it will
release for Xbox one in Windows 10
October 11th I believe in the RET God
said stay tuned a game spot for more
news until then yeah thanks Scott